allez un bon soir on vous avez vu une
interview de hans blix là c'est étonnant
quand même
il dit oui bah oui avait pas de preuve
les mecs nous a complètement manipulé
ça s'appelle se [ __ ] de la gueule du
monde voilà entier ekwalla george bush
est annulé pour des mots et voilà tout
cela
[Musique]
un message de georges pour dire toi même
alors albert dupontel acteur auteur
réalisateur aujourd'hui c'est l'acteur
que nous recevons pour un film de
nicolas boukhrief qui s'appelle le
convoyeur avec jean dujardin françois
berléand vous sorti le 14 avril
c'est le troisième film de nicolas
boukhrief et le film se passe dans une
société de convoyage de fonds
c'est la première fois c'est bizarre
mais ni les français ni les américains
ni personne n'avait pensé à ça avant
alors c'est marrant d'ailleurs cessé
convoyeur cd ouvriers en fait on gagne
un bruit enfin c'est bizarre c'est des
mecs qui gagnent un salaire de misère
pour transporter des millions mais se
fait par chris grey en vie oui ça fait
partie des aberrations de la société
voilà actuelle la même façon qu'il ya un
président des etats-unis qui dit qu'à
des armes qui n'existe pas il ya un an
2000 euros par mois des ti pour
transporter des millions d'euros dans
des fourgons c'est un peu un peu
aberrant un peu hypocrite un peu faux
cul un peu anti sociale comme vous dites
oui antisociales c'est très bien
documenté une enquête qui a été fait par
par une journaliste avant et tout est
vrai dans ce film pas tout tout tout
mais ils n'ont pas démenti la globalité
alors voilà c'est un film qui était un
suspense sur un fond sociétal
on pourrait dire j'en voulais parler que
c'est dans les voilà il va les émissions
culturelles un mot soucier table très
bien si c'est un film noir un film de
genre qui rend compte la vie d'un groupe
emblématique de la société actuelle et
ses conseillers mec paumé qui sont armés
avec une tentation permanente évidemment
depuis que le fric qu'ils transportent
ça quand même un paradoxe effectivement
alors j'ai vu votre personnage alexandre
se fait engager par cette petite société
de transport de fonds
les affaires vont pas bien on parle de
vente villans
dépôt de bilan vente aux américains donc
un certain stress d'entreprise
effectivement qui doublait d'un stress
et dès qu'ils sortent du fourgon qui
peuvent faire de leur vie et au travail
peuvent perdre leur boulot ça fait
beaucoup quand même
alors en plus cette petite société est
victime de deux braquages répétés alors
on se demande s'il n'ya pas une
complicité entre les convoyeurs et les
truands qui est qui les attaquent et on
se demande qui vous êtes au départ on
voit arriver alors on se dit ça impôts
mais qui a trouvé un boulot il fait ça
parce qu'il sait pas quoi faire d'autre
ensuite on pense que c'est un flic
peut-être qui est en train de
d'infiltrer la société pour savoir qui
organise ces braquages
on pense que peut être vous même
d'ailleurs un braqueur évidemment je
vais pas vous dire
espérant conjoncture c'est une défense
du film c'est vrai qu'à 45 minutes on
sait pas ce qui se passe ni ce qu'il
vient faire et pourtant présent son
fauteuil et vous 45 minutes quand le
mobile apparaît du monsieur je le trouve
très touchante les émouvant et fort
voilà alors le personnage c'est un
personnage comme ça très costaud très
musclé on voit faire de la gym et tout
en même temps d'une grande fragilité en
toujours l'impression qui va partir quoi
ce deal et nicolas maîtresse est assez
joli c'est habile scénaristiquement et
au niveau du cinéma c'est de dire on va
montrer la force plutôt que de la voir
la jouer comme ça on va garder le jeu
pour l'émotion la maladresse le
pathétique le ridicule d'un grotesque le
pato est ce que tout ce personnage
véhicule un peu comme le dr saxe dans un
autre registre un peu comme dampierre
d'irréversible voilà c'est des registres
que j'aime bien ouais alors on souffre
quand il fait de la muscu mais on
souffre encore plus quand on croise son
regard quoi est quelque chose qui se
dégage de lui qui est assez pathétique
d'ailleurs puisque quand on vous voit là
vous allez l'aï allumé malicieux mais
dans le film vous êtes vraiment des cons
paye tout est possible
tout était bien payé il ya du jardin
aussi jean dujardin qui est excellent
c'est pas du tout j'ai pas la télé
d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas la télé
non c'est pour ça que j'aime bien ces
chargements jamais venu si j'avais
l'émission avant non mais là jean
dujardin je connaissais pas et qui est
très sympathique berléand exceptionnel
voire me connaissait par ailleurs claude
perron que je connaissais sans avoir la
télévision et nicolas marié qui joue
également dans le dernier d'un créateur
et une flopée d'autres acteurs vraiment
formidable quoi une grande réussite de
boukhrief que je salue j'avais vu le
personnage est éminemment doux et
sympathique intègre authentique voilà
très bien on l'applaudît alors ça sur le
14 avril
alors j'ai mis antisocial tout à l'heure
parce que c'est quand même assez anti
social vous en vous en convenez non vous
avez été renvoyée d'école maternelle à
quatre ans et demi c'est quand même pas
mal non archives
c'est assez vrai le pire c'est vrai et
ensuite vous étiez à l'école paul bert à
conflans et on était obligé de vous
mettre du chatterton sur la bouche pour
vous clouer le bec suis effaré par bourg
enseignes ne vous rendez compte quand
même temps et toujours c'est le secteur
5 ans et un fumier d'instituteurs
certainement pédophiles mais l'époque
c'était motorisés qu'aujourd'hui un qui
m'a foutu du chatterton sur la bouche
rencontre j'avais voulu brûler sa maison
non il ya cinq ans quand même j'étais
petit j'étais pas si vous voulez violé
sa femme quand
j'avais repéré que ce fumier je savais
où il habitait et acheter des glaces a
clairement quelle adresse
j'ai sans portable j'ai tout et je me
rappelle qu'il avait une coccinelle à
plusieurs fois j'aurais bien vu cette
coccinelle partir en fumée
voilà sans façon walt disney recul
social la seule chose qui arrive à vous
calmer un peu c'est la gym ouaip il ya
pas que ça ait des parents gentil
surtout qu'ils m'ont un peu calmé un peu
dirigé la drogue la drogue à celle tout
voilà une relation incestueuse on peut y
aller et puis non non je faisais
beaucoup de sport un petit mois j'étais
assez assez agitée de l'essence ce qui
vous calme est plutôt c'était le cinéma
vous passiez votre vie enfermée dans les
salles ça je fuyais la réalité comme
vous je sais pas comment vous l'avez
fait q vous n'avez fut la réalité
certainement aussi puisqu'on sait qu'il
aime un vision vous continuez au cinéma
bref c'est encore pire
voilà il y avait ainsi des mots bout de
la rue s'appelle le palace alors alors
j'allais vraiment papa qui était docteur
à la même rue et je disais j'ai besoin
d'argent pour acheter des fournitures
scolaires ça se terminait par un lié à
10 15 ou 20 francs à vous rentriez à
deux heures de l'après midi vous sortie
à minuit les foi potter fin jeunes gens
rentraient plus tôt et puis un peu plus
vieux en plein jour à traiter tous est
d'eric rohmer achats sont d'ailleurs
j'avais c'était la synergie pas de la
cinéphilie
alors ensuite vous suivez l'orientation
paternelle pour devenir médecin a fait
quatre ans de fac de médecine
jusqu'au jour où aux urgences albert
dupontel vous voyez débarquer à un mec
de 20 balais complètement bousillé par
un accident de moto et là vous vous
dites il faut vivre il faut faire ce
qu'on a envie de faire dans la vie parce
que finalement ça tient à rien quoi en
fait j'ai été un peu et ils m'ont mis à
pied pour un stage tout le monde était
soulager les malades comme les médecins
que je m'en aille
c'est vrai j'avais été très frappé par
six mois du rejoint exactement à
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy c'est
franchement la nuit vous imaginez pas ce
qui se passe j'ai frappé je me dis si
vivre c'est avoir des émotions autant se
dépêcher des soins parce que c'est assez
aléatoire
là vous vous inscrivez un cours de
théâtre et puis après bob on connaît la
suite il ya eu d'abord le one man show
qui était extraordinaire c'est à dire il
fait des sketches comme le bac français
comme rambo et c'est un truc que j'ai
pas compris vous avez un tel succès
quand vous avez commencé à faire des
sketchs bien je vous ai dit non ce que
je faisais du cinéma et vous avez acheté
sa carrière je vais toujours faire du
cinéma mais le spectacle a été la
poterne qui m'a permis de rentrer dans
la forteresse du showbiz c'est une sorte
de cri primal mais je trouvais ça pauvre
et frustrant fin que je voulais faire du
cinoche bernie la bande dessinée du
spectacle le créateur la bonne division
avec le prochain enfermés dehors sera
toujours en cas d'accord
voilà il ya une bernie évidemment le
créateur ensuite l'acteur avec des films
aussi important que la maladie de saxe
de ville alors vous êtes très lonesome
cowboy un vous vous êtes très anti
société du spectacle dizaine de comptes
à rendre à personne je vis comme gandhi
je n'ai besoin de rien on ne peut pas
m'avoir le vrai luxe dans ce métier
c'est la liberté de dire non ou de dire
oui je suis aussi franc que bush
non c'est vrai vous je suis un peu
discret voilà ça suffit d'être
marginalisés pourquoi pas mais je suis
un peu discret c'est tout je suis pas je
suis pas hystérique avec les médias
j'avais failli être un peu les gens à la
télé ça la culture de l'ennui la télé
comme ça vous êtes une agressivité je
peux agressive et c'est vrai que moi
j'ai pas la télé depuis dix ans je m'en
passe très bien et heureusement je les
ai pas je vois beaucoup de films j'ai
800 dvd milka 7j bras et voilà et la
télé qu'on arrache à l'automne gère l
affaire j'ai regardé ces foules chose de
choses inutiles à part votre émission
mais des choses inutiles qu'on peut voir
non mais je mangeais agression survient
non non mais je pense que cette émission
est utile qui vient non mais souvent ya
un procès par exemple enfin je ne lâche
pas on nous a fait un gros procès et sur
bernie sur la violence au cinéma et
souris à bercy de gens parlent pas ce
film là d'ailleurs pas interdit aux
moins de 12 ans je tiens baptisé donc
ils passent ils ont ça
toutefois je mets donc j'ai pas la télé
mais l'audience au cinéma c'est un faux
procès est ce que le cinéma est un lieu
protégé
c'est un lieu de polémique d'expression
de débat mais ses protégés auront pas
une salle de cinéma au hasard le met
quotidien vrai rêve à ciment famille
c'est franchement il s'est gouré c'est
un consommateur crétins tant pis pour
lui pargo la télévision rend dans la
chambre d'hôtel craque on appuie sur le
bouton je tombais sur lci et semaine
dernière
les mecs qui brûle dans la jeep les
américains dépassé par la foule j'étais
très choquée parce que j'étais paperasse
ah ouais donc une perversité eux se
cache derrière l'alibi de la formation
entre alibi d'information et voyeurisme
il ya un truc une frontière qui franchit
allègrement donc le procès de la
violence au cinéma
montcuq quoi ça n'existe pas cesser le
jeu mais qui va au cinéma voir un film
qui sait ce qui va voir sauf si c'est un
combat soeur c'est de tester la tb comme
ça non mais je n'aime pas ce qui me fait
pas de montant voilà sauf quand je suis
là bien sûr c'est pas une attitude un
peu snob ça non écoutez franchement
d'abord elle est involontaire c'est un
jour un jour m'a coupé cas parce que je
payais pas donc au départ je voulais
voir et puis je me suis rendu compte que
je pensais que je mens pas ça très bien
donc non mais c'est pas un peu snob ne
pas payer le câble l'interview un parmi
d'autres
[Musique]
j'ai déjà l'émission jamais pardon
jamais de lui cette émission une fois
d'ailleurs j'ai été très choqué j'avais
presque envie de venir en courant
c'était quand il y avait un philosophe
parisien type closerie des lilas qui
s'appelait finkielkrault oui c'est ça
c'est un nom qui ressemble un quart en
un clic droit et qui expliquait en gros
que les palestiniens est il cette étape
désespérée mais qu'ils avaient le
désespoir pas très poli puisqu'il a
laissé faire sauter chez les gens j'ai
trouvé ça totalement indécent elle est
tellement grossier et malvoyants qu'il a
réussi à faire pleurer la délicieuse du
lait de bidoche
moi je vous souhaite un débat
profondément choquée je vais parce qu en
visite en bretagne de prendre la voiture
et d'intervenir sur le plateau et dire
voilà parce que quand on en arrive à se
faire sauter avec des cartouches de
dynamite c'est qu'on est franchement
désespéré voilà il n'y a pas de
politesse ou pas avoir des espoirs donc
[Applaudissements]
cette émission à l'inter
heureusement que t'as pas la télé sites
en bretagne c'est pas prendre la bagnole
faire 500 banques pour mettre un bon
pays fin mais quelle connerie ouais
imaginons serait pas trop regarder alors
un parmi d'autres donc si vous étiez un
des sept péchés capitaux vous seriez
lequel la luxure je ferai plus souvent
la télévision parce que si vous étiez un
des dix commandements tu ne tueras point
comme ça je n'hésiterai pas un des sept
nains simple est comme ça je pourrais me
présenter à la campagne présidentielle
américaine
il ya du gras chez toi aussi si vous
étiez un dessin elle maintient le
dernier le 101e pour être le chouchou
est une des sept merveilles du monde
les jardins suspendus de babylone qui
aujourd'hui se trouve à bagdad comme ça
je ferai du jardinage avec interdiction
pour les chars de marché sur la pelouse
à un bravo
si vous étiez un des cinq sens l'odorat
pour m'autodétruire la promotion des
films au jeu vous étiez 1,17 à le cinéma
pour apprendre quelques trucs un des
quatre points cardinaux du sud pour
pouvoir perdre le nord en permanence en
bravo si vous étiez à les trois
mousquetaires d'artagnan pour piquer les
ferrer la reine plutôt que de lui rendre
sa couronne
voilà est un des sept mercenaires du
brenner pour avoir une coupe de cheveux
toujours à la mode ça vous étiez albert
dupontel un des douze travaux d'hercule
les écuries d'augias en faisant passer
le fleuve par matignon l'elysée
l'assemblée nationale l'a si vous étiez
un des 31 jours du mois le premier
pendant les vacances et dernier pendant
que je travaille si vous étiez à 17
jours de la semaine le lundi parce que
tout est encore possible et un des cinq
continents l'afrique pour me venger
c'est
claude perron et albert dupontel
bonsoir bonsoir claude bonsoir albert
bonsoir monsieur dessous albert en vous
quittant pianiste virtuose dans fauteuil
d'orchestre de danièle thompson et on
vous retrouve en sdf déjanté dans votre
nouveau film qui s'appelle enfermés
dehors alors le pitch c'est un sdf qui
trouve un uniforme de flic et il va s'en
servir pour aider une femme interprétée
par claude a retrouvé sa petite fille et
se casse sociale devient en fait sa
raison d'exister il décide de jouer les
justiciers voilà vous dit que le pitch
m'est venue un soir où je songeais à me
venger du monde extérieur
c'est à dire un peu tous les soirs il
dit ensuite j'ai cherché comment
raconter et l'aspect cartoon sociale m'a
paru de bon aloi
c'est vrai que c'est un cartoon sociale
voilà voilà c'est la meilleure
définition du film
en plus si vous le dites moi je pense
que c'est ça à thoune en gros et social
un petit ces récompenses aux police mène
de chaplin
mais la réalisation est traitée que
savent rire oui chuck jones aussi ouais
ouais tu la bd fil mais quoi et ben
voilà je suis absolument d'accord je
suis pas qu'on était sur écoute
alors c'est un film assez c'est
burlesque qui fait ma règle des choses
désespérées comme tout ce qui est
burlesque quoi désespérer les algériens
on prend le terreau social qui existe et
puis on parle de ça je comprends pas
d'un constat on travaille en panne à
porter une révélation aux gens si c'est
une révélation qui a désiré dans la rue
des banquiers véreux le 20 heures est
une tragédie
par contre l'idée c'était d'avoir un
procès des grands guigne cartoonesque
finalement pour raconter tout ça comme
un monsieur qui a fait ça très bien il
ya cent ans et s'appelait chaplin c'est
une revisite très humble et très
personnelle des corps nus chaplinesque
voilà alors vous dites ce film est né
d'une attitude inconsciente qui consiste
à regarder les travers du monde avec un
nez rouge c'est vous quoi ben voilà oui
mais c'est plus drôle que bernie quoi
ces derniers étaient drôles aussi mais
simplement qu'il y avait un côté il ya
un côté plus bénins dans ce personnage
là puisque dès le départ ses ambitions
sont plus triviale il veut boire manger
et être aimé le regard ni vu ça frustre
itude vouloir un nom était déjà quelque
chose de très exagéré points
quoi voilà donc ces pouvait lui dans le
mur voilà mais c'est la fin positif de
ce film est aussi honnête que la fin
négative de vernis l'etec s'arrêtait une
faute de goût de faire ce film mal se
terminer
voilà on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
j'ai regardé tous les deux la caméra
vous allez dire magnéto serge sécail
rouge claude voilà hockey manille dont
toi aussi un pardon manier tout en même
temps 1 2 3 mais les doutes persistent
mais si par exemple tu es de la police
un tu fais un coup bas la police il ya
une dame qui te demande de l'aider dans
la rue dit cette dame par exemple elle
te dis qu'on lui a pris son bébé si siam
est cyclique
je me lavais sucer le clark a fait sa
peine au dessus des matelas gueule c'est
des gens il faut les décapiter vivant et
lapidé à coups de hache et j'en fais tu
pâte et du papier
[Musique]
à
j'ai toujours été attiré par les poules
c'est le nouveau kindle
dakar
or il est vrai que les tiges d'éventuels
vous êtes dans tous ses films dans
bernie dans le dans le créateur dans
enfermés dehors et vous avez dit en
parlant de claude je préfère les grandes
actrices rare aux mauvaises très
fréquentes
ça j'étais sûr c'était jour de détails
qu'elle et lui plaît c'est un petit peu
le nombre de chats foule je demande est
acquis qu'il pensait okello personne
c'est vrai que je trouve que mal avec
l'os et 1 5% qui piaffent et jamais
utilisée il faut sur le mode d'emploi
donc voilà non mais c'est débouta que ça
c'est pas sérieux thierry le film n'est
pas sérieux je ne suis pas sérieux rien
n'est sérieux voilà vous avez beaucoup
vous dites son animalité sa tendresse en
même temps il a peut-être qu'elle peut
l'expliquer mais pour moi ça reste en
page et animale animal peut-être dans le
sens où je suis plutôt instinctive que
cérébral en tout cas pour le jeu et
d'ailleurs dans la vie aussi sujets
phares gfa déçoivent de swaps et voilà
pourtant au départ ils assistent pour
une actrice espagnole à votre place
quand même elle est morte
ah oui c'est vrai oui j'ai fait un
contrat contre il ne faut pas déconner
ça s'est pas fait avec l'actrice
espagnole dont il est mort voilà donc il
a il a ramé pour vous pour vous re
conquérir au il en a chié de télé quand
elle joue vous l'avez attendre longtemps
avant de dire oui j'ai pris mon temps
j'ai fait le tour du périgord
non non non ça c'est pas fait comme ça
tout à fait donc il ya eu cette actrice
espagnole parce qu'il voulait en fait
enfin ils vous diraient mieux croit il
voulait que ce qu'elle soit étrangère
pour accuser encore le fait qu'elle soit
perdue par rapport à l'administration
française et pour récupérer son bébé et
puis et puis donc elle était plus jeune
aussi pour encore le côté plus
vulnérables et donc il est resté encore
en pensée sur cette jeune personne dans
l'idée donc petit à petit sous la menace
la torture il a fini par réaliser qu'en
fait il avait en face de lui le gars de
beaucoup mieux au départ c'est une
coproduction franco espagnole en fait
alors au départ même avant ça c'était un
projet américain vous avez tenté
l'expérience américaine vous avez pensé
à robin williams et jack nicholson
l'appel du pied du cinéma indépendant
américain et en être vaniteux j répondu
voilà avant un sursaut de lucidité dans
venir en france mais j'ai perdu un petit
peu tanger que j'ai croisé des personnes
très intéressantes et très très
enthousiaste vous dites ils sont
marrants comme celle soir mais le
lendemain on est en face de leurs agents
et c'est déjà beaucoup
donc c'est facile de manger avec eux de
s'amuser et c'est authentique mais dès
qu'on commence à travailler c'est
compliqué et puis surtout je peux avoir
pour elle je pouvais pas voir le
contrôle de mon travail ça me gênait
beaucoup donc je suis revenu en france
précipitamment et j'ai reconstitué une
petite équipe de verdure claude voilà a
été beaucoup plus sage plus vous avez
passé quand même temps la barre où je
fais des allers retours pendant 18 mois
selon m
vous n'êtes pas acharné hollywood quoi
non non non non faut pas alors le film
s'est monté en france n'est pas évident
d'arriver à le monter parce que c'est
vrai que le créateur savait pas été un
énorme succès non mais c'est ça c'est
surtout une question de le principal
investisseur du cinéma enfance et la
télévision et la télévision est
forcément friands de ce genre de
produits voilà j'aime bien n'est jamais
passé en clair ceci peut être que ça
donc j'ai pas d'où du matin à m j'ai un
score au box-office n'est pas forcément
le kadima s'est ou non mais c'est
logique aussi çà - doit savoir c'est une
partie du talent c'est de savoir se
vendre il faut aussi penser à un film
culte
et derrière thuram pour faire des cubes
c'est bon parfois je ne me plains pas
donc je connais les règles du jeu on
vous dit je m'ennuie souvent au cinéma
surtout avec sept postes nouvelle vague
qui n'en finit plus de mourir c'est que
souvent le cinéma à l'étranger français
doit être considérée comme la nouvelle
vague
quand il faut des films qui ne ressemble
pas la nouvelle vague ils sont surpris
dit c'est pas du cinéma
je suis fou dans la cuisine où pierre
est parti parce que karol arriver c'est
vrai qu'à plainte si on a quelques
expirations de quelques quelques eu
quelques expériences aux états unis qui
était curieuse ce qui est des gens
venaient ils sortent en disant c'est pas
des cinémas français donc on était un
peu embêté on était un trip
culturellement la nouvelle vague a fait
des dégâts malgré tout pour les petits
gars comme nous quoi voilà c'est tout
alors c'est fini le wegmans pour
toujours et ça fait 15 ans mais vous
verrez pas au truc quoi non non non je
mange ça me manque pas voilà vous avez
fait en fait des courts métrages avant
de faire des sketchs les sketches et
juste une façon de faire connaître
finalement c'est une porte qui s'est
ouverte j'ai réussi à toujours les gens
comme sebastian marafa la télévision
parce que ces sketches à s'amuser
beaucoup mes copains à l'école de
théâtre où j'étais chez vitesse et c'est
vrai que c'était il ya 15 ans a duré 18
mois je me suis jamais projeté dans une
carrière là-dessus avec les ou du
spectacle à titre d'anecdote j'ai
produit mon premier court métrage
qu'elle désirait que dans les bonus du
dvd du créateur
et puis voilà ça s'appelle avoir la
suite dans les idées et ce succès est
encombré quelque part non pas du tout
sincèrement ça me frustrait puisque
jamais la caméra tu le sais très bien
souvent parler donc j'aime bien cet
outil qu'est la caméra chaud ça très
beau très souple ça me fascine à tora
réseau j'en sais rien ça me plaît
beaucoup
la scène de frustré parce que je n'étais
que tout - seul sur scène tu as été
frustrant comme expression donc voilà
donc c'est juste ça j'ai pas arrêté par
roger j'ai arrêté parce qu'il y avait
une femme plus belle qui m'attendait pas
c'est aussi bête que ça
bien voilà enfermé dehors donc sorti le
5 avril alors le film le pitch comme je
les dis c'est un sdf qui enfile un
costume de flic alors offert une
interview si vous étiez free
vous étiez plus que ce serait pour
quelles raisons non pas par nécessité de
manger voilà je pense un crs qui
s'énerve actuellement dans les manifs
c'est s'ils pouvaient faire notre boulot
je crois qu'il le ferait ouais bah oui
je pense et ce quasi fasoli mis en 68 il
a dit les vraies prolétaires ce sont les
crs sans aller jusqu'à cet engagement
politique je pense sincèrement que c'est
ma classe il pouvait éviter de le faire
ils le feraient quoi c'est comment on
les manipule on leur fout sur la gueule
et les étudiants les flics ses trousses
assez consternant comme spectacle un
jeune un flic qui se bat avec un un
jeune en banlieue c'est un pauvre qui se
bat avec un pot et ça fait juste
quelqu'un qui manipule tout ce petit mot
sur sa totalement d euros parce que la
personne qui voit sa voiture brûlée à
mettre dans la merde
par contre la personne qui ça profite
fera monter les cotisations d'assurance
et sa voiture sera jamais brûlé
puisqu'ils les victoires même quartier
donc je trouve ça un peu désire vraiment
anti sociales cdc pas anti sociale est
ce que disent et de la compassion j'ai
eu de la compassion pour ces gens et je
comprends les deux camps je suis navré
de voir le spectacle
la société actuellement de séjour de
droite et de gauche qui se foutent sur
la gueule ça me désole quand il ya autre
chose à [ __ ] dans ce pays codes sont
dues les a priori sont toutes les
compétences requises ce qui n'est pas le
cas de leurs heures ni de moi des lieux
rhin il pourrait faire les choses bien
et on les voit sont violées dans des
débats puérils et ça je trouve ça
désolant franchement ya beaucoup de gens
dans ce pays qui n'ont qu'une envie en
fait c'est que c'est trouver des
solutions parce qu'il ya des problèmes
mais la juvénilité la classe politique
est absolument navrant j'ai parce que le
sentiment que la masse à ce qu'on
appelle la masse silencieuse le masses
populaires a plus de maturité région qui
nous dirigent j'en suis sûr regarde moi
je vote pas j'assume complètement
non non non
ils sont très disciplinés à chaque fois
soyez vous pouvez dire de manière non
mais j'en ou pouvez m'insulter le droit
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est si je vois tu es je voterai blanc
les votes blanc n'étant pas validé en
france du coup je me retrouve un peu
embêté c'est parce que je me reconnais
aucun discours mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que si le vote blanc est un et
d'été validé on pourrait être façon
pacifique et intelligent influencer sur
démocratie dont je rejette ce candidat
là je range est il est pas normal qu en
2002 on est le choix entre le pire et le
moins pire je veux dire c'est un grand
pays ce pays normalement c'est ce que
j'entends dire partout on en a eu 30 %
de votes blancs et on aurait recommencé
les élections et c'est pas plus mal
jusqu'à citer des candidats qui plaisent
aux gens le vote blanc crée de la valeur
que si le vote est obligatoire
pas forcément mais s'il ya des tas de
gens qui rêvent de voter blanc de façon
changer la règle du jeu
oui mais si le vote est obligatoire le
vote blanc serait considérée beaucoup
pour booba donc en commençant par donner
le vote blanc est en tout cas d'états
gens iront voter aujourd'hui le vote
blanc donne là une voie à donner sa voix
au plus fort malheureusement si elle si
tu veux si tu avais je te dise il était
valide constitution loi n'existe pas le
vôtre actuellement six ont décidé que 15
ou 20 % de votes blancs étaient pouvait
invalide une élection des tas de gens se
mettrait à voter de façon à changer
pacifiquement la règle et d'un jeu que
personne ne comprend actuellement c'est
ce que je dis actuellement wauquiez vont
effectivement revient pas faire grand
chose donc voila moi quand on sait pas
pour qui voter on peut sans risque
oui si vous étiez flic est ce qu il en
mettrait le plus bas des deux flics n'en
est pas des flics par contre les flics
c'est un boulot difficile et qui n'a pas
forcément la considération des jeunes
autour de soi quand il n'ya pas de bons
flics et de mauvais flic c'est pas vrai
relais des effets meute qui se comptant
en même temps il ya des effets me tout
d'un coup il ya comme des mauvais
supporters tu les prends appareils sont
gentils sont entendus galles mais je
reviens il ya quand même des gros
courant comme un peu comme partout si
vous étiez clics vous arrêteriez qui en
première moi même
voilà pour éviter de faire des conneries
tout ce pouvoir et vous laisseriez filet
qui si vous étiez de flics
moi même je reprends ma liberté oui je
crains c'est que vous soyez sûr qu'ici
vous étiez flic personnes les meubles
feriez quoi comme bavure des films bonne
réponse ne fait pas tout ce qui vous
demande de faire voter blanc et vous
j'adore le trône aussi [ __ ] c'est une
catastrophe
c'est bien mais moi ça me ferait plaisir
ça ça voilà
j'ai je me sens plus je m'arrête je me
sens fier le site de dell je ressens
fier d'être français voilà dit c'est
bien l'esprit critique il faut percer
infiniment du fond du coeur voilà une
chefferie courrier surtout avec quel
accessoire le sifflet pour faire du
bruit sur les défis que vous espériez
plus les noirs ou les arabes
la connerie ce métier flics vous seriez
un peu excité chaque fois vous passer
des menottes à quelqu'un si j'étais tout
nu peut-être je sais pas j'aime essayer
tuner thieffry que j'utiliserai quelle
méthode pour faire parler les gens
le vote blanc vous étiez fait quel délit
laisseriez-vous impuni le le pétard pas
déconner quand même
le pétard oui les pétards faut qu'ils
arrêtent de nous emmerder c'est arrivé
vie paraît que c'est très dangereux un
coin un coup sur deux il y avait un
rapport comme quoi c'était une drogue
douce ya deux ans puis maintenant c'est
très dangereux de deux ans nous dira je
croyais pas je me faut arrêter c'est
très bien passé mais jusqu'au prochain
rapport
ouais mais soit meilleur que le dernier
si vous avez fait qu est ce que vous
seriez hameau à nicolas sarkozy je
démissionnerai
c'est l'heure
les corrections des ratés de
l'inhabituelle abonnez vous il m'était
impossible